[Musique]
particulièrement présents depuis le
début de cette épidémie le médecin
michel cymes fait aujourd'hui parler de
lui pour son côté business man
selon le magazine capital avec ses 53
publication en quelques années ces
conférences seront autorisés par le
groupe harmonie mutuelles son
application médicale son programme pour
bien évidemment financé par auchan
changer d air sponsorisé par dyson ainsi
que le podcast au fil de l'eau financée
par la marque et zac
sans oublier ses nombreuses
participations à des émissions de télé
michel cymes est à la tête d'un
véritable empire car en plus des
animateurs le docteur s'intéresse aussi
à la production toujours selon capital
michel cymes qui détenait 24 8 % de la
société de production pulsations a alors
vendu 11 45% pour 1.5 millions d'euros
il a également obtenu plusieurs actions
dans le groupe new one qui l'a
finalement revendue à tf1 sans oublier
que l'an passé michel cymès a vendu au
groupe webedia le club santé la société
qui organise ces conférences à travers
la france pour la modique somme de 11
millions d'euros est en véritable
businessman le docteur a su s'entourer
pour tirer le meilleur parti de son
business michel cymes est entouré de
bons avocats fiscalistes afin de réduire
son impôt toutes ces activités sont
détenus n'ont pas en son nom propre mais
par une société baptisée du nom de sa
grand-mère glee cas alors le très juteux
business de michel cymes révélé choquant
ou pas choquant
alors avant à avant vous nous donner
votre avis sachez que michel cymes
déteste quand on lui parle d'argent en
août 2010 8 le magazine love a consacré
un article sur le business de michel
cymes et regarder ses réactions
c'était sur france 5 regarde on parle
d'argent à michel cymes salah gas vous
répondez quoi d'argent on sait pas que
ça m'agace c'est que c'est pas que ça
m'agace c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'un
article me concernant et la journaliste
de loeb ça a été super elle m'a suivi
pendant plusieurs jours c'est toujours
le même grain même question est combien
vous gagnez est ce que vous gagnez trop
est ce que vous n'avez plus machin en
france on peut pas parler d'argent de
toute façon on sera aux états unis tout
le monde aurait balancé sa feuille de
paye depuis je paye en france dés que
vous parlez d'argent on dit google ni
trop donc voilà je vole pas mon argent
si on veut parler de jeu idéal à journal
je suis dit bell voulait venez avec moi
l'hôpital regardez combien je fais de
patients dans la matinée je gagne 70
euros la matinée que je fasse deux
patients ou que j'en fasse 20 d'accord
donc ça veut marquer là aussi mais on
peut pas parler d'argent en france on
est tout de suite mal vu alors voilà
donc voilà que michel cymes avait mal
pris un conte lui parle d'argent
est ce que vous êtes choqués par le
business de michel cymes ou pas du tout
il fait énormément d'activités ou dit
c'est normal qu'il y ait de l'argent
bien vous dit non avant tout c'est un
médecin et il devrait se consacrer à la
médecine dit la vérité
et voilà vous pouvez dire des choses
bien sûr michel cymes un jean-michel
mersch
non moi je trouve c'est un mélange des
genres assez gênant parce que pour moi
j'ai peut-être une il y eu une idée un
peu folle les points quand les médecins
sacerdoce mais déjà bien payé mais on
consacre sa vie auprès de serment
d'hippocrate aux conques ou consacre sa
vie à soigner des gens quand un
animateur un animateur devient
producteur et créent des émissions il
craint le business autour de ça c'est
dans l'ordre des choses
sauf que là il est médecin pourquoi il
lance des bd des banques 1 les sites
internet terra c'est une sorte de
pieuvre de l'économie souterraine et des
tentacules comme ça qu'ils m'ont un peu
partout moi je entre toutes ces
activités la préparation de ces
émissions la gestion de son patrimoine
immobilier ce qui paraît que la dei
beloeil peu partout la relecture de cbd
l'écriture de ses bouquins je serai bien
savoir que même temps il passe à
l'hôpital
donc quand on voit michel cymes le
verrez ça devrait écrire en dessous
businessman
médecin de formation
concept génial en jambes mais
aujourd'hui aller matthieu delormeau
jamais pardon aujourd'hui c'est quand
même fou cette idée que quand on est
médecin pour forcément être pauvre parce
que j'ai pas d'argent donc il ya ya ya
ya des grands chirurgiens qui sont
propriétaires de cliniques et qui sont
millionnaires moi ça me choque pas du
même mois michel cymes qui dit des
bêtises sur le corps un virus comme on
en lit pendant trois semaines ça ça me
choque que michel cymes vendez pas créer
une société de production et même à la
limite qu'ils soient un peu moins
médecins et d espagne
il fait ce qu'il veut de son diplôme
tant qu'il fait pas de bêtise donc moi
qui gagnent des millions ça ne me
dérange pas et si on parlait pas bon
j'ai pas me faire un pote que vous allez
bien cyrille mais si on va là dessus
pardon pour moi c'est pas plus choquant
là ils gagnent beaucoup d'heures que 15
stéphane plaza qui au début était juste
animateurs maintenant il a des centaines
et des centaines d'agents ce grâce alors
je suis pas d'accord avec vous j'adore
stéphane et je le défends la somme en
jeu c'est mon pote monfils c'est pas
pareil c'est dans son domaine et moi et
moi et moi je comprends tout à fait que
michel cymes gagnent beaucoup d'argent
après n'ont alors rien voilà il fait ce
qu'il veut mais ses fans panacée dans
son domaine il a joué oublier fait de la
janvier si vous m'aviez dit michel cymes
il a créé des cliniques voilà je dis bon
voilà c'est ça j'ai pas voilà mais là
c'est le bon exemple n'est pas bon ses
fans de la série
mika est tous assez sur la médecine
fréquemment rapport ouais non oui mais
non alors sophie cost apprendre à me
renier paquet pas content sauf non moi
je suis je suis assez d'accord avec
mathieu c'est à dire qu'effectivement il
décline à l'infini à l'infini il est
partout il se fait sponsoriser par
toutes les marques possible il écrit
tout ce qui peut et sait il a eu cinq en
cas de publication
c'est énorme enfin je veux dire le mec
être extrêmement prolifique après bah là
il fait du business
probablement qu'il adore l'argent il
très lavage tant qu'il ya du lait bon
bah c'est plutôt assez louable tant
mieux s'il gagne tant mieux s'ils
viennent du blé après c'est vrai que son
discours un peu moralisateur en disant
je m'intéresse à la vie à la santé des
français
je pense qu'il s'intéresse beaucoup à la
santé de son pel pour le moment j'ai
apprécié cette ville le site le 6 mai et
la pêche al kilani c'est cabral se
parler d'argent c'est tabou il a raison
parce que moi je connais il ya au collet
touche plein de jeanne qui ont gagné
de l'argent par anne deriez mais
toujours dans le même devenir amis mais
il est toujours dans la mer le maître
qu'il a produit des emplois le mec il a
je vais même si metz
il produit quoi eh bien pu lui avant je
m'attarde lui est mais là où il a
commencé à me n'y fit c'est qu'elle
tiacoh gazier a critiqué le professeur
[Rires]
je suis d'accord mais cela cadet du
défunt thompson à grenay vidéo relais
rené je vais pas te mentir
rené je vais pas te mentir c'est pas un
pote à moi donc je m'inquiète pas d'où
pouvait tout dire
michel cymes et papotent je te le dis
donc tous nos matches on vous dit ce que
vous les mêmes sur des balkans que tim
hug qui n'était pas couverte n'a autant
qu'elle inquiète pas t'inquiète pas oui
un vrai bon là dessus et apprendre à
jouer
moi ça me dérange plus quand il vient en
tant que médecin on sait que maintenant
c'est plus un médecin quand il dit je
passe mes journées à l'hôpital comment
il fait pour passer les gens on à
l'hôpital n'était pas certain qu'on
mettrait pas fin à saucisse ça nous
aiderait beaucoup parce qu'il dit qu'il
est à l'hôpital qui peuvent être autant
de temps à l'hôpital
autant la télé à la radio ça c'est un
premier point après qui vient de son
argent tant mieux s'il veut garder son
argent mais qui disent bien qu'il ait pu
docteur et qu'on vous dit mazza c'est
pas pareil garden ramsay c'est pas
pareil lignac c'est pareil c'est
exactement pareil on voit bien des
animateurs télé des animateurs radio
faire autre chose que lors que leur
métier d'animateur radio on les voit
faire des trucs sans le voir dès la loi
dont il a doit doser
julien courbet qu'on adore et
l'animateur il fait des trucs pour
laisse naître il est pas de sur son
métier il a accosté attendons le nom
mais parce que gilles halde juste ilan
est juste si metz il faut pas qu ici qui
disent maintenant sans arrêt je suis
docteur il sera docteur après sa télé
quand il en a fini comprend que c'est
sommet pour l'instant regardez moi juste
mais après je vous laisse tranquille
juste moi il ya des gens il propose 800
euros pour aller faire guignols en boîte
de nuit
mille euros pour aller faire des photos
sur instagram l'autoroute pourquoi es tu
le sais cyril a même des gens qui m'ont
dit tu es un livre sur ce qui est arrivé
j'ai pas envie pour l'instant je reste à
ma place j'ai programme mec mais on sait
pas jean-michel en europe
on peut tourner la chose dont tous les
sens mais étaient revenus des revenus
d'offres quand même correspond à ton
métier si lui il est quand même 90%
sinisé d'indiquer que je sois hors de la
médecine et bah ils gagnent eux
consultant à bfm business que
consultance mais toi tu es journaliste
de guerre jean michel tu es journaliste
de guerre et le soir tu chantes ans
catherine lara embry médias rené
véhicules et tu l'aimé bien non tu
l'aimé bien michel cymes avant qui
critiquent le professeur à oopa bas du
reste néanmoins convaincu maintenant
c'est pas trop ça
gérald avait rarement entendu parler de
lui parce que je m'intéresse pas ce
genre de truies moi je connais mon
docteur de famille je connais des bêtes
qu'ils avaient entendu parler de raout à
marseille le dessus mais non émettrices
en jeu jamie shell jeu le businessman la
débine a renouvelé si ces jours-ci
michel cymes était devant toi tu lui
dirais quoi sur le professeur à ou si la
ville les gens devant moi je leur
enverrai à ses études à ce mec tu le
direct le match je vais faire un malheur
qui tu veux tu peux bien te quitter me
voir moi j'avais vivait reclus me dis
waouh
alors venez fêter à michel cymes oui
bonjour michel cymes heures
moi je vous dis voilà votre placer
raoult et bat pour moi il dit des
conneries m'a dit eh ben moi je dirais
tu toi pas qu'un gros cols rouges à la
vie aia
c'est vraiment garder monnaie pourquoi
mais c'est vrai que j'ai dit voilà j'ai
terme est assez fade de professeurs ou
parce qu il tente des choses mais ce qui
m'a énervé c'est les conneries qu'il a
dit michel cymes ou plutôt le fait
qu'ils critiquent le professeur
franchement s'il ya des baisses au 5
août
eric moi j'achète est passé dit ouais
d'accord mais c'est pas qu'il a il a
critiqué ronde je ne supporte pas tout
ce qu'est ce qu'il a à dire
le critique à cannes où les maires des
grandes villes
super compris cela leur avait aussi nos
collines à cna le magma de gars là bas
c'est la petite d'arthur qui quitte à
violer les orients gay le mal de noms
mais où mathieu laisse le laisserait
tranquille la lettre les tranquilliser
dans son lit dans son truc me
parlez-vous déçu face de toi pour les
venets mais il a dit quoi son
professorat ou michel cymes et pas sur
une relance mais il a dit qu' il n'était
pas que c'était durant l'entracte pur de
dany le rouge elle a atteint quand même
pas daniel koch a dit tu te permets de
dire on ferme sa gueule mais il va bien
c'est plus tu portais sa chérie mais je
supporte pas moi moi c'est supportable
je veux dire suis avec toi là dessus
j'ai avec toi là tu t'emmerdes par tu as
chaud là dessus voilà bon et si tu avais
tu vas jamais ce lundi que tu lui parles
et dont essayer de faire une
confrontation
ok moi - tim white ouais mais bon marié
d'accord vous va très bien donc c'est
d'ailleurs je suis fan je suis fan de
ces approches moi je suis fan de
l'imaginer vous aussi vous êtes mort de
rire à l'état quelqu'un d'ailleurs qui
nous demande sur twitter rené pourquoi
tu aimes pas michel cymes syrie tiré
j'ai des retours sur martigues et j'ai
des dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
d'abonnés qui prévoit les retours que
j'ai de l'émission alors il aimait 10 m
de kock casser les couilles de rome gars
là nous n'avons ni qui va la melli mal
c'est marion milk et ils sont contents
que je sois là et et mettez toutes les
missions m ou rené moi je suis
extrêmement content que tu sois là et
c'est pour ça que je veux tu sois là
avec nous tous les jours je le dis je
suis fan de toi je t'adore je suis très
souvent d'accord avec toi dans tes
analyses en plus est dans tes choix de
personnes que tu aimes et que tu aimes
pas donc j'aimerais qu'on est souvent
d'accord on est souvent d'accord tous
les deux sur les je connais les cônes
aime pas beaucoup plus ça ça me fait du
bien parce que ça c'est rare dans
l'équipe